Oh,
I don't think judges at our level,
I don't think much about public,
I think the Supreme Court does because
you know,
it's interesting example of a couple of
years ago,
they,
the court of Appeals for the Ninth
Circuit,
which is California number.
Then western states decided that the
phrase under God in the pledge of
allegiance was unconstitutional and
that caused a certain sensation.
But on the other hand,
it was just the ninth circuit.
It was just the West in any way.
It was subject to appeal the Supreme
Court.
Will,
the supreme court found a technical
ground for reversing the decision they
didn't deal with.
The issues of religious freedom that are
involved was very technical.
Now,
if the Supreme Court decided under God
in the pledge of allegiance was
unconstitutional,
that would have a tremendous impact.
Uh,
and I,
I think the supreme court justice is
consciously or unconsciously
are mindful of the public opinion
consequences of their decision.
But at our level,
our decisions,
we rarely have significant effect on
public opinion.
So the response to the public is not,
is not a factor,
but on the other hand,
there's no doubt that judges idea
ideological views and political
responses and moral feelings and so on
are influenced by the,
uh,
the temper of the,
of the community.
So some of us think,
well,
we mean by morality is durable public
opinion,
right?
So the judges will share the morality of
their community,
which is ultimately a product of what
people feel.
So,
so public opinion has a tremendous
underground effect.
The courts are all more conservative,
for example,
than they were in the sixties.
So there's been an ideological drift in
the country
and
equivalently has been a change in public
opinion that's affected who's been
appointed as a judge but also affected
how.
How'd you.